antonia is in her last year of high
school
just looking at her you'd say she's a
healthy happy 20 year old but a couple
of years ago things were pretty
different
i've come to linchpin sweden to find out
what things were like when antonia was
17. back then her life was ruled by
anorexia
how would you describe your feelings
towards your body
i just hated
myself i just didn't like myself it
didn't matter it was just not enough
and i think that's why i kept losing
weight as well like he first was like oh
just if i lose a few kilos i'll be
happier
with myself
and then i wanted to lose more kilos and
more and it was new goal weight and a
new goal weight and it was never enough
once again there were enough and then i
almost died
and then i realized that it's never
going to be enough because that's not
the problem after starving herself for
half a year antonia's organs shut down
this is from my bed
when i was admitted to hospital
and from there i've documented it so
um
pictures from
the hospital and from when i was put in
hospital and
what it was like
and then it goes all the way to today
really
yeah and then this is it
ah yeah i can show you antonia posted
the pictures on instagram
while we're looking at the pictures
i show her thomas
i don't know
so do you like those kind of bodies
well he's very fit
but do you think like people can be too
muscular
yeah they can but he's he's not too
muscular but if people are like so big
that they don't look human or like
then i
think it's too much but i am i think
that he still sometimes feels too skinny
yeah can you understand that phoenix i
think a lot of people it's like here
they want more and more and more kind of
when you start growing you just want to
keep growing
researchers say that one in a hundred
teenage girls suffers from anorexia it's
the mental disorder with the highest
mortality rate
while 46 percent of patients recover
from the disease 34 percent show only
some improvement and 20 percent
eventually die
i was scared of food and if i was scared
of being hungry or craving food it was
like the worst feeling i knew so i'd
avoid any social
um things where food was involved
like eating with the family or
parties or whatever
because i was so uncomfortable
and when i did eat i i knew i was eating
too little so i'd lie a lot and say that
i'd eaten when i hadn't and so on
um
but i wouldn't even
can't be able to handle it if someone
would tell me then like you have to eat
this for breakfast
i'll be like
never i'd rather die
you're a bit hungry antonia's doctors
put on a strict meal plan now she eats
six meals a day
pretty healthy stuff too
if they pick something so what is it
exactly again
protein oats
with zucchini
um topped off with raspberries and
peanut butter
antonia works out a lot so she needs the
energy but just a couple of years ago
she used to count every calorie
i kind of liked the hunger it was a
then i was doing it right
i felt i like i didn't like feeling full
antonia's been documenting her recovery
from anorexia on instagram where she has
almost 40 000 followers she says they've
helped her keep going
now she's also writing a fitness blog
so that's your blog yep
here it is
this is where the magic happens
do you know how many people actually uh
read your blog uh yeah i can check
statistics um i can check how much today
so far antonia used the internet when
she was sick too
but then it only made her worse
i'd compare myself a lot and
the girls would like the pro ana
vlogs they like
um
they want you to starve yourself kind of
or they like push you to and give tips
on how to lose weight and things like
that so that was a really negative
effect would you refuse to look at that
kind of stuff now yeah or i find it
really difficult
because i get so angry and upset and it
hurts so much because i know that there
are girls who read it
and
use every trick they can and it's sad
it's so sad and i it's so sad that
someone would sit writing that
not understanding that they could kill
someone
like don't they understand that they can
actually kill someone
it's insane
now she avoids posting anything online
that could trigger other people with
eating disorders especially her weight
still there are thousands of girls out
there posting exactly that and a lot
more
pro anna is a code word used on social
media by people who say anorexia is a
lifestyle choice and not an illness
users exchanged photos of emaciated
bodies and extreme weight loss tips
i tried to get in touch with some pro
ani users for our show but none of them
wanted to be on tv
to be honest a lot of the pictures i see
online don't look that different from
models or even kids toys
society seems to be telling us that
skinny is beautiful so where's the line
between healthy dieting and mental
illness
to get some answers i meet up with a
psychotherapist who specializes in
treating eating disorders
it's like anorexia is not socially
accepted but
we
there are many behaviors leading towards
that that are socially accepted we have
a society that is obsessed with food in
different ways either it is eating a lot
eating little or eating
special things
i only this i only ate that for 10 years
ago who would have come somewhere and
said i don't eat the bread and just take
the cheese
and roll it and eat today that's totally
socially acceptable this body hatred
that a lot of people have
where does it actually come from we know
that body esteem is an important part of
young people's and everybody's
self-evaluation
in mass media it's of course about
surface because that's all you can see
so i think it kind of gives us the
impression that people that look a
certain way are
happy or have a good life or something
so i think it becomes we think that
looking a certain way is not a goal it's
the means to achieving the kind of life
we want to live
yeah that's i can easily imagine
her younger sister henrietta stays with
him sometimes too
back then it was mikael who first
confronted antonia about her eating
disorder
by the time he noticed what was wrong
she was just skin and bones
i think i was
extremely shut off
or when we had
a traumatic
management years in the family as this
has been a dysfunctional family for many
years
and a lot of bad things has happened
the way she is that's how she dealt with
it she's like the good girl who always
performs and does her best even if even
if it means becoming a very good
anorexic so to speak
uh or or getting well
um so but she's still working with her
issues of course
even though she's
well a long way away from where she was
so would you say from from this journey
that um
now antonia works out at the gym almost
every day
when you say you're a body person
somehow sure i work out and it shapes my
body and so on
i do care about my body but i care a lot
more about how i feel
than how it looks
and that's a big difference but sure
yeah i do care about my body
but i owe my body
i really feel like i owe it
when antonia was anorexic she exercised
excessively
all she cared about was burning as many
calories as possible
it's been a long time since antonia came
to this park
two years ago when she was recovering
from anorexia she used to come here
almost every day
well when i was in hospital this is
where i i would take my walks uh when i
was and i had to start walking
and it was only 15 minutes a day but
um
it was like my minutes of freedom each
day
learning to eat again was just part of
antonia's recovery she had to dig deep
for reasons to keep going
this was my life list
when did you write that when i was in
hospital it was like my motivation in
recovery so i had it with me everywhere
in my back pocket
and if i
didn't want to
if i got a panic attack or got worried
or um didn't want to eat or whatever i'd
read the list and it would make me fight
a bit harder
so what does it say
i want to live for my little sister i
don't want to be a sick role model for
her i have to be strong and i have to
get healthy i have to live for her
i want to live for my family and my
friends i love them too much to die
i want to live to travel
because i haven't seen enough yet
i want to live for love because one day
i'm going to fall madly in love i want
to live to work out and have energy
again i want to be strong
i want to live for my education because
i have so much to learn
i want to learn to inspire i want to be
an inspiration for others and show them
that you can get healthy
i want to live for children because one
day i'm going to be the world's greatest
mom
i want to live to be free i want to live
because
i have too many things that i can't give
up now and i want to live because i
refuse to
lose does it make you sad to read that
now
no happy happy i think because i i did
it
i know i can do anything
basically i i almost died and i survived
and that's a really empowering feeling